practically all better now let's go to
Wisconsin
[Music]
check it out my autograph it looks just
like a dick unfortunately steeple signs
every don't let it shake and let's go
what's the most you autograph McCartney
how much well work for some guys so I
got 300 350 each and he probably gets
like seven eight hundred each
I got like Keith Richards like four or
five years ago he's still sitting on
those I said it mostly dies but people
died their value goes up right like dude
like I just weird thing man after every
show that I ever do and take photos with
the entire audience every single person
I might as well cuz kind of in my head I
want to when I die have more pictures
with people than anybody you've that
problem yeah I take a lot of [__]
pictures man I've been waiting my whole
life for something like this
[Music]
[Applause]
you got a [__] great tattoo right
there brother make mother and daughters
matching jackass tattoos
[Music]
taking photos an audience of 1,200
people starting route to Lambeau Field
Lambeau Field
how do you know they're figuring out
what's the giveaway Oh
crazy thing about the stadium and
there's not a bad seat in the hole
a chef
[Applause]
[Music]
I've never seen that but they pull
and that's a wrap on the Wisconsin tour
just like what do I want to say I don't
know thanks for watching